okay so so far we've been talking about
first order logic and it's syntax and
semantics and now what we would like to
do is you like to talk about inference
rules for first order logic in this
module we are going to be talking about
modus ponens when we have only horn
clauses and in the next module we are
going to be talking about resolution
when it comes to first order logic okay
all right so if you remember what
entrance rules do is they basically do
symbol manipulation so they take the
formulas the syntactic form of the
formulas and they have like no notion of
meanings or anything of that form but
based on the formulas that are in
knowledge base they basically try to
infer they try to derive or prove a new
formula based on what exists by
syntactically moving things around kind
of like what we have seen in modus
ponens for propositional logic right
so
what we would like to do is you like to
focus on applying modus ponens to first
order logic when we are under a scenario
where we are have only horn clauses
and if you remember horn clauses were
definite causes and goal clauses and
definite clauses were of the form of
having some some set of prepositional
symbols so p and q for example implying
pp1 and p2 for example implying some sum
q so some positive literals ended with
each other implying a new positive
literal so how do we extend that idea of
definite clause to the space of first
order watching
so if you want to look at definite
causes in first order logic you're going
to have a set of variables and you're
going to have quantifiers on top of them
so for example
this is an example of a definite clause
where we talk about for all x for all y
for all z and then we have these
predicates takes x and y
and ended with another predicate covers
y and z and that implies a whole new
predicate knows x and z okay so we have
kind of like these atomic formulas ended
with each other and we have we have a
set of quantifiers outside and this
implication okay
so basically if you prepositionalize
here we get one formula for each value
of x x y and z so so if you remember
prepositionalization from the from the
last module what we can do is we can
basically think about x y and z taking
specific values like x being alice and y
being cs221 and z being mdp and if you
think about each one of these values
like each one of these formulas taking
one value for uh for each x for each y
and for each c and then we end up with a
prepositional logic formula that ends up
being actually definite clauses
but we would like to be able to
represent this in this more expressive
way and and
because of that we are defining definite
clauses in first order logic using these
variables and using these quantifiers
and so on so more formally a definite
clause has the following form so so it
has this form of having a for all
quantifier for x1 for all through for
all xn where x1 and x8 through xn are
variables
and and we have these atomic formulas a1
through a k and b all of these are
atomic formulas and we are adding these
atomic formulas a1 through a k and that
implies b and remember these atomic
formulas actually contain these
variables x1 through xn so so they are
they actually have x1 through xn inside
of them containing them okay kind of
like this example up here
all right so this is a definite clause
in first order logic so how can we do
modus ponens in in first order logic
okay so if this is a definite clause for
all x one through x and a one added
through a k implies b
one possible attempt maybe our first
attempt in looking at modus ponens is we
have this and in addition to that maybe
in our knowledge base we have a one
through a k and based on that we should
be able to derive b based on these
premises maybe we can conclude b okay
so does this work does this does this
definition of modus ponens work
let's look at an example so it turns out
that it actually doesn't work so so
let's look at this example where we have
p of alice so p is a predicate over
alice and maybe that defines our a1
and then we say for all x p of x implies
q of x okay
and ideally what should i get from this
ideally i would like to get q of b from
this
but i'm really not able to do that well
why am i not able to do that because
remember modus ponens is an inference
rule inference rules don't really know
anything about semantics or meanings so
they're basically just matching symbols
and if i'm just matching symbols first
off p of alice has nothing to do with p
of x so i can't really match p of alice
and p of x so i'm kind of like screwed i
can't like this i can't apply this modus
ponens idea on top of it and then in
addition to that if i even if like i
could somehow say p of alice and p of x
are the same thing i i'm not going to be
able to get
here q of alice because q of q of alice
and q of x are very different things so
i can't infer q of alice and then i also
can't really like match p of x and p of
ours they don't really match here so
this modus ponens like the rule that
i've written here just doesn't work this
is not the modus ponens that we should
be using in first order logic
so how are we going to solve this
so there are two ideas that i'm going to
be talking about in this module
substitution and unification and
substitution and unification are the
things that are going to make our
improve our modus ponens and help us
apply modus ponens in first order logic
so let's look at what they are so what
is substitution
so what substitution does is it takes a
substitution rule that substitutes a
variable with a term
and it takes a formula and it basically
takes that formula and substitutes all
those variables with those terms that it
is given okay
one thing to notice is it's going to
substitute a variable like x with a term
and what is a term if you remember our
module on syntax of first order logic a
term is going to be either a constant
symbol
or another variable
or a function okay so here in this
example alice is a constant symbol so
i'm replacing a variable x with a
constant symbol alice okay
here's another example so i'm
substituting x with alice and i'm
substituting y with z with another
variable in this formula p of x and k of
x and y okay so so i'm doing find and
replace basically i'm doing find x
replace it by alice find x replace it by
hours find y replace it by z
and and that is what substitution does
so substitution theta it's a mapping
from variables to terms and substitute
theta f returns basically the result of
performing that substitution on a
formula
okay
all right so what does unification do so
that was substitution that's great so
what does unification do so what
unification does is it takes two
formulas and it tries to match them as
closely as possible and unification
returns a substitution rule that tries
to match those formulas as close as
possible so if i'm doing unify knows
alice arithmetic and knows x arithmetic
i have these two formulas i try to match
them as close as possible and the
substitution rule that matches these as
close as possible is replace the
variable x by alps okay so that is what
i'm going to reject
let's look at another example so i might
have unify knows alice y and knows x z
okay so what is a substitution rule that
gets me there i'm going to get a
substitution rule that says
replace x variable x by alice replace
variable y by z and and that is going to
be the substitution rule that i'll get
out of unifying these two formulas
here's another example so i have unified
knows alice y and knows biopsy
so this is going to return fail the
reason it's going to return fail is i'm
not going to be able to substitute a
symbol a constant symbol by another
constant symbol remember we are
substituting variables by terms and
there are no variables here to
substitute there are two there are two
constant symbols or two terms right so
so i'm not going to be able to
substitute these so i'm going to get
failed from unification here
and here's another example so i might
have knows alice and y and knows x and f
of x a function here right so so here a
substitution rule is take the variable x
replace it by alice and takes variable y
and replace it by f of l so i'm taking
the most general form of this where i
could have f of x here but because i've
already i already know in my
substitution rule that x needs to be
replaced by alice instead of putting f
of x here i'm putting f of alex i've
already like replaced x by als okay
so what is unification well what does it
do more formally it takes two formulas f
and g and it returns the substitution
which is the most general form of a
unifier so to unify f and g two formulas
return of theta so then if i if i do
substitution of theta and f that gives
me the same thing as substitution of
theta in g and it returns fail if such a
such a substitution doesn't exist okay
so why am i defining these so the reason
i'm defining unification and
substitution is i can now modify my
modus ponens and i can use this idea of
substitution and unification in order to
make modus ponens work in first order
logic so here i'm going to have
different a1 prime through a k prime
these atomic formulas from a1 through ak
and different b prime than b these are
going to be different atomic formulas
okay specifically if you think about it
these a ones prime through a k prime are
are groundings of this a1 through a k
which basically operate on on these
these variables x's and b again operates
on a variable on x and b prime you can
think of it as a grounding of b okay and
then b prime and b or a1 prime through a
k prime they don't look the same right
so that's why i can't syntactically just
like replace them by each other but what
i can do is i can use substitution and
unification what i can do is first up i
can look at my a1 prime through ak prime
my groundings and then these other
atomic formulas a1 through ak and i can
unify them
so once i unify them i get a
substitution rule theta
and what i can do is i can i can derive
b prime and what is b prime b prime is
going to be the result of substituting
theta in b and that is going to be my
new modus ponens rule okay so i'll end
up getting a grounded version of b b
prime and how do i get that by
substituting theta and b and where do i
get theta i get theta by unifying a1
prime through a k prime and a1 through
ak okay let's look at an example
so let's say that in my knowledge base i
have a premise that says alice takes
cs221 so this is my first version a1
prime which is a grounded version of x
taking y and then i have
cs221 covers mvp again it's a grounded
version of why taking z so what i do is
first i do a unification of of these two
formulas and these two formulas and
based on that unification i'm going to
get a substitution rule that
substitution rule tells me that take
variable x replace it by alice take
variable b means sorry take takes and
take variable by replace it by cs221
variable z replace it by mvp
and then what am i going to do right
what am i going to return out of modus
ponens modus ponens basically tells me
that this is your b you want to return
kind of a modified version of b and what
is that modified version that modified
version is using this substitution rule
over your b or over this nose xc so if i
if i substitute theta in nose xc i'm
going to get alice knows mvp and that is
the thing i'm going to be returning that
is the thing that i'm going to be
deriving here or proving here and that's
basically applying modus ponens in first
order logic
so let's think about the complexity of
this is this how is the time complexity
here and and how how bad is this so if
you remember
when we were doing modus ponens in
propositional logic every time we were
running mode exponents we were adding
one we were adding one prepositional
prepositional symbol right in in the
prepositional logic line here every time
you're running modus bonus you're only
adding one atomic formula which is which
is not bad which is actually pretty good
okay and in addition to that if you
don't have any functions right if if
there are no functions going on here
then the number of these atomic formulas
is at most the number of constant
symbols that we have to the power of
maximum predicate area so so in this
example for example i might have p of x
y and z and maybe x takes a hundred
values y takes a hundred values and z
takes a hundred values
so then i'm gonna get a hundred to the
power of three which is which is not bad
but the thing is if there are functions
here
then we actually end up with an
infinite number of them being applied to
each other so this becomes unbounded so
if i have if i have a function over a i
can keep applying that and then i end up
with an infinite number of things being
added in because i can keep applying the
function on it it on it so remember like
for example the sum uh function that we
saw like earlier in one of the examples
we had sum of three and x right so i can
keep applying some on top of each other
on top of itself and almost like
recreate like arithmetic by applying
some on itself but we are going to get
an unbounded number of formulas here
which is not that great okay
all right what else do we know about
modus ponens so so the thing in modus
ponens in this space of first order
logic so what we know is modus ponens
turns out to be complete for for first
order logic with only horn clauses this
is a similar type of completeness that
we have uh when we look at uh when we
look at modus ponens and prepositional
logic again if you are limited to horn
causes we have completeness in first
order logic as well
in addition to that we know that first
order logic only when it is even only
when it is restricted to horn causes is
semi-decidable so so what does that mean
what that means is if that is that if
our knowledge base entails f
and then we want to figure out if it
entails f or not but if it actually
entails f and we keep doing forward
inference we keep trying to derive a new
formula until convergence uh using modus
ponens this forward and inference until
kind of like complete it until we get
like these complete inference rules and
and getting f takes finite time so so if
my knowledge base actually entails f i
should be able to derive f in finite
time i should be able to prove f by just
inference rules and finite time which is
pretty nice
but with the difficulty that gets me to
semi-decidability is if knowledge base
doesn't entail f and i might not know if
knowledge base entails it for a dozen
entailment right like if i don't know
and actually knowledge base doesn't
entail f it turns out that there are no
algorithms that can show this in finance
time
okay so so
and then this is actually kind of
related to halting problems so so there
actually people have shown that there is
like no algorithms that that could do
this in finite time and we are kind of
screwed in that case okay
so in general this is not too bad in
general you can think about having a
budget for the amount of time that
you're going to run your inference role
and run it and see if if you get lucky
and nkb actually entails f you're going
to be able to get f in finite time so so
you could actually run uh first modus
ponens with first order logic when you
have horn clauses and and and it does
it does work in some instances but then
kb actually entails it
but then in the next module what we
would like to talk about is you want to
go beyond modus ponens and we want to
talk about resolution specifically how
resolution would work in first order
logic